uploading a data set to the hub
in this video we'll take a look at how
you can upload your very own data set to
the hugging face hub
the first thing you need to do is create
a new data set repository on the hub
so just click on your profile icon and
select the new data set button
next we need to assign an owner of the
data set
by default this will be your hub account
but you can also create data sets under
any organization that you belong to
then we just need to give the data set a
good name
and specify whether it is a public or
private data set
public data sets can be accessed by
anyone
while private data sets can only be
accessed by you or members of your
organization
and with that we can go ahead and create
the data set
now that you have an empty dataset
repository on the hub the next thing to
do is add some actual data to it
you can do this with git but the easiest
way is by selecting the upload file
button and then you can just go ahead
and upload the files directly from your
machine
after you've uploaded your files you'll
see them appear in the repository under
the files and versions tab
the last step is to create a dataset
card
well documented data sets are more
likely to be useful to others as they
provide the context to decide whether
the data set is relevant or whether
there are any biases or risks associated
with using the data set
on the huge face hub this information is
stored in each repository's readme file
there are two main steps that you should
take
first you need to create some metadata
that will allow your data set to be
easily found by others on the hub
you can create this metadata using the
dataset's tag and application which
we'll link to in the video description
once you have created the metadata you
can fill out the rest of the dataset
card and we provide a template that
we'll also link to in the video
and once your dataset is on the hub you
can load it using the trusty load
dataset function
just provide the name of your repository
and a data file's argument and you're
good to go